الفرات العظيم قد لا يدوم عظيما تركيا
قطعت نصف مياهه وشتاء لم يسعف النهر بامره
كانت هنا قبل بضعه السنوات
قبل ان تتراجع كل هذه المسافه الى ادنى
مستوى في تاريخ النهر
الى هنا وذلك بسبب تقلص الوارد المائي الى
200 250 متر مكعب في ثانيه من اصل 500 متر
مكعب متفق عليه مع تركيا
الواقع الجديد هبط بانتاج الكهرباء من
السدود الرئيسيه ودفع الاداره المحليه الى
زياده التقنيين الذي شمل ايضا مياه الري
وشرب كما فاقم المشاكل الصحيه جراء تلوث
مياه النهر
لقطع الماء حاسه من تركيا هذا غلط لازم كل
العالم
توقف معانا يعني
المسؤولون الاكراد رهنوا هذا الشتاء على
الامطار لتخزين كميات اكبر من المياه في
السدود الا ان غيابها شكل صدمه للجميع
الموسم الشتوي الجاف الثقافه ان يكون هناك
ربيع جاف علينا وصيف اييي يعني مخيف على
مجمل انتاج سدود من المياه الشرب او قنوات
او الطاقه الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
ورغم المخاطر التي تهدد حياه المليون
انسان في سوريا فقط لا تزال مشكله نهر
غائبه عن طاوله الحوار بين تركيا سوريا
والعراق كم يبدو ان الاطراف الدوليه غير
مهتمه ببساطه تحول دون وقوع الكارثه من
الرقه جمع عكاش العربيه